can pile of people tend to think of
YouTube as a platform for you know 24
year-olds and younger like it's a kids
Channel you know there's vloggers and
Shane Dawson and all these fun people
there however we see that it's a very
powerful force I mean here's shown that
saw arnelle's
videos that were uploaded from an
internet cafe took hours and hours to
get up and here he's discover this man
and it's totally changed things
how underrated do you think YouTube is
for filmmakers or artists of all kind
I don't know that YouTube is underrated
I think it's well rated I mean it's very
well respected I mean Justin Bieber was
found on YouTube right jatin um it's
just amazing to me I mean like literally
when I started in this business there we
didn't have email like I didn't have
email when I started this business and
now I do stuff and I'm like how could
I've ever crude or you know sent out a
tremendous amount of information without
email like and here we are in a digital
age where it the world is like turn this
big it's so super small and it's it's
just connected us all I mean it's
beautiful yeah it definitely has and
with that there's also chance for people
to comment anonymously and do all sorts
of stuff and some people seem to still
be holding onto the fact that there's
only one journey should Perry but when
you hear arnelle's voice when you see
him on stage when you hear his story you
know that no there can be two journeys
there's still the beautiful journey with
Steve Perry and that'll never be
replaced and then there's the new
journey with arnelle how much do you
think some of the people's own issues
with the fact that they weren't
discovered on YouTube plays into that
because so many people that are artists
they have a hard time as I've done it it
happened so easily for someone which we
see that it really wasn't an easy night
or they struggle a lot I never thought
of it like that like arnelle says in the
film I'm gonna say I am also a very big
fan of journey I mean of Steve Perry he
was a very big fantasy fairy I was a
huge fan of Steve Perry and journey
and I do understand where they're coming
from some people are resistant to change
or might feel loyalty but the fact is
you're in love with the music and the
music makes you feel good and Arnelle
sings with music so beautifully that I
think like like you said I think the
people that are sort of out there and
they're the haters they just need to
take a minute in and either watch a
portion of film even just a trailer or
watch our now perform I think that he
gonna win them over you know it's the
music and music connects us all
you